and tonight we're seeing some changes
come to one busy intersection where a
woman was struck and killed while
crossing the street on her mobility
scooter that was back in november near
las vegas boulevard and silverado ranch
now the area has become a concern for a
nearby senior living facility let's go
out to victoria saha live she heard from
residents who hope more can be done
there
[Music]
yeah that woman who was struck and
killed in this intersection just lift up
the road in a senior housing community
but now you can see fresh absolute on
the ground being placed for a makeshift
sidewalk so it can be easier for
residents to walk along this busy road
i personally went down to the corner
and the traffic there is
really really
tremendous roxanne murray wanted to see
for herself how hard it is to cross this
busy intersection although she isn't
disabled her husband ambrose is in a
mobility scooter just like their
neighbor stephanie turner was when she
died trying to cross the road it's very
upsetting for us because a lot of us had
seen her that day residents in the
senior housing facility are demanding
change so they don't have to be scared
for their life as they cross the road
it's like building a school and not
having a school zone
you know the seniors need to have
the safety commissioner michael naft is
in charge of this area usually traffic
changes at intersections take a while
but he says this was a priority case
when it's warranted the county just
needs to step up and get the job done
sometimes turning the dirt roads into a
pathway but for resident chris milleron
who uses a walker to catch the bus
across the street it's no easy task we
try not to go anywhere if we have to at
night
we try to do everything during the day
where people can at least see us hoping
they don't lose one of their own again
now these residents are hopeful more
changes will happen like a crosswalk and
more lights commissioner naf said his
office will look into those suggestions
reporting live near las vegas boulevard
and silverado ranch victoria saha live
local now